you have your own asteroids yes I do yes
I do I'm sorry I don't mean to brag or
anything by the way there a lot of
asteroids so there there's a limit to
how big your head can get but you get an
asteroid named after you just saying
yeah I don't know about that that's not
bad I mean can you see it now that
that's thing um the person who discovers
the asteroid right has the power to name
it after any person place or thing wow
that I'm gonna say so that's that's an
honor that's honor that's more than an
honor that's like that's like naming a
child after somebody you know okay okay
I mean honestly that asteroid is going
to be there long after we're all gone
your kid's going to die if you named
your kid after me it'd be like okay
that's an honor for like what 70 years
three score and 10 all right it's not
like your kid's gonna live forever you
know I was named after Chuck Nice no but
that asteroid will be there for
generations to come long serious honor